SETH LADD: Hi, my name
is Seth Ladd.
I'm a developer advocate
with the Dart project.
In this video, I will introduce
you to the different
parts of Dart and explain how
Dart can help developers be
more productive, building
faster apps
for the modern web.
Dart can be a productive
environment for developers new
to the web, especially
developers familiar and
comfortable with structured
languages and tools.
You can use Dart to scale from
small scripts to large apps
that take advantage of the wide
array of HTML5 features.
Dart apps compile to JavaScript
and run across
modern desktop and
mobile browsers.
The Dart language is designed
to be easy to learn for
developers that are familiar
with C#, Java, ActionScript,
and JavaScript.
It is a class-based,
object-oriented, dynamic
language with closures, lexical
scope, and more.
As you can see, the code syntax
looks familiar and is
easy to learn.
Dig a little deeper, and you'll
find some cool features
like optional static type
annotations for inline
documentation, safer concurrent
programming with
isolates, libraries for code
organization, and more.
The language is easy to use
with your favorite text
editor, or with our lightweight
and productive
Dart Editor.
Dart Editor can help you create
a project, explore
unfamiliar APIs with code
completion, update the code
with refactoring and quick
fixes, find problems early
with inline warnings and
errors, and much more.
You also have the option of
using Eclipse and IntelliJ, as
both products support a rich
Dart editing experience.
Once you've written some
Dart code, you can
run it in two ways.
You can run your app across
modern desktop and mobile
browsers, thanks to our
third-generation Dart to
JavaScript compiler.
For faster app downloads, Dart
to JS eliminates dead code
from the generated JavaScript.
Dart to JS also generates
source maps, which tells
browsers how to debug the
original Dart code, even when
it's first compiled
to JavaScript.
For even faster performance,
quicker startup, and a
productive debugging experience,
Dart programs can
also run natively in the
Dart Virtual Machine.
This new VM was originally
designed by the same team that
built V8, Chrome's fast
JavaScript engine.
The Dart VM is built
for speed.
For example, VM snapshots
improve application startup by
up to 10 times.
The VM can power command-line
Dart scripts that access
sockets, files, processes,
and more.
You can even build your own web
server with the Dart VM.
But with the VM embedded into
web browsers, developers can
quickly test their apps without
first compiling to
JavaScript.
You can debug your apps directly
from Dart Editor by
launching into Dartium,
our custom build of
Chromium with a Dart VM.
Using Dart Editor with Dartium,
you can launch the
app, set breakpoints, inspect
variables and objects, and
step through the code.
Developers experience a fast
edit/reload cycle, thanks to
the editor's integration
with Dartium.
Building new apps with the
editor and Dartium is fun.
But developers often need to
integrate with existing
libraries and code.
Now there's a way to call
existing JavaScript libraries
directly from Dart.
You can use JavaScript APIs like
Google Maps, or your own
in-house code, without first
porting it to Dart.
But perhaps there's already
a port of your
favorite library to Dart.
To discover, install, and
manage third-party Dart
libraries, use Pub, our
package manager.
A simple configuration file
declares your application's
dependencies, and with a quick
command, those libraries are
downloaded and installed
for your app.
Pub makes it easy to share your
code, install libraries
from other developers,
and keep your
dependencies up to date.
As you can see, Dart is much
more than just a language.
To try it out, you can join
our open-source project,
download Dart Editor, and
learn more about Dart at
dartlang.org.
We look forward to
your feedback.